- [Questioner] Should I launch
my business on the side,
(Gary clears throat) (crowd murmurs)
- [Man On Right] Thanks, man.
or take a gap year and try to launch it?
- Both work.
- Both?
- Which one is the best?
- I don't know you well enough, you know.
You know what I mean?
They both work.
- Yes.
- Which one do you wanna do?
- [Questioner] I would like
to try to take a gap year--
- So take a gap year.
- but I'm scared.
- Well that's why you're asking.
- [Questioner] Yes,
which one would you do?
- I wouldn't take either.
- [Questioner] What would you do then?
- I can't answer that for you.
Fear is holding you back,
you know what you wanna do.
The only reason you're not doing it is,
you're scared of doing what
you actually wanna do, right?
- Goodness, that's right--
- Are you scared to do it
'cause your parents won't like it?
- [Questioner] No, my
parents actually support me.
- Okay, so what are
you scared of, failing?
- Not failing, but still
being at the same place,
when my friends are at the next level.
- Huge mistake, you don't want
the same thing your friends want.
So why the fuck do you
care what they have?
Number one mistake so many people make
is they care about what other people have.
I don't give a fuck what anybody has.
If I have more, if I have
less, it doesn't matter,
I worry about myself.
The fact that you're worrying
about other peoples' accomplishments,
is already a losing formula.
You need to get rid of that first,
then you can focus on yourself.
- [Questioner] Thank you.
- You understand?
(inspirational music)